[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm beryl
and this week we're looking at desserts
or puddings or
sweets whatever you call it it is
non-savory food week
yay the world was not always addicted to
sugar
in fact the original sweeteners were
honey and dried
fruit but then we got sugarcane
sugarcane is actually originally from
new guinea but the plant made its way to
india and there at around 100 a.d
are the first instances of sugar
refinement the crop spread to the middle
east and china rather quickly but it
didn't get to europe until around the
12th century and it really only got
there because of colonization
my dog smells the donut i'm
recording hey
there's a lot happening right now since
then sugar has taken on
many many forms
ice cream
[Music]
cake perfect
french tiny expensive cookies
[Music]
chocolate jello
[Music]
what's good there is a lot out there
there's no way that i could cover it all
i mean at least not in a video like i
make i'd be out here forever it'd be
delicious though
but i chose desserts that i thought were
interesting and that maybe you hadn't
heard of before
because we're all curious people right i
spoke to seven people
in seven countries to see what desserts
were like
around the world so this is the dessert
episode
in making this episode i decided two
things one
i'm not gonna do instant desserts so
nothing from a box
sorry betty crocker and two i wanted the
desserts to have a connection to the
culture that we were in
sorry one last thing before we start the
video i know that i could only cover
seven and i'm sure that i missed some
amazing desserts out there
so let me know in the comments where
you're from and what the best dessert
from your country is because
i am super interested and i bet other
people are too
my future self thanks you okay let's
start the video
[Music]
there is
[Music]
found in indian households the red
carrots particularly are quite sweet by
themselves
so it's a sweet dish with a nice crunch
of nuts to it
palm tree drink poppy bella breathe my
article
von hintendod panel nine and poppy barra
breath and they fought
here legato is
fabric
antimatter it is
[Music]
foreign
okay let's begin so first up
a dessert from turkey that leads with a
non-traditional ingredient
chicken
[Music]
is
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign i saw this dessert on great
british bake off and was totally
intrigued
did not disappoint
my barra breathing got a cafethy memory
seasoning
speckled bread breathe a dilhane
ayurvarag
i'm speckled nlv i'm going if
i don't be one teddington and i'm
inclined i'm on doing any day call or
gumbery
my energical torso is
[Music]
and grenade to the wall and vlas is the
own
with moya ana then they'd better breathe
they kind of could someday be
owned by a climate
andromeda
[Music]
danny drosterrock on the far guard i
didn't see that on her property
tori slayson i had a many needs
[Music]
talmud
[Music]
in colombia this dessert has a deep
rooted history with not only the city
but the people who make it
is
[Music]
[Music]
i chose this dessert from japan because
it is made out of something that i would
not consider a dessert
beans
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
whenever i'm in india this is what i ask
for after dinner
the carrots here work perfectly in the
desert
is made out of the things that you
usually find in your kitchen my name is
anar
i live in gujarat india this recipe was
taught to me by
my mother-in-law her recipe of gajar ka
halwa
is really loved by all our family and
friends khajar
is like carrots and halwa is like a
pudding made with wheat flour
semolina another vegetable gajar
halwa is cooked grated carrots in milk
or cream
and then sweeten it with sugar the red
carrots particularly are quite sweet by
themselves so the amount of sugar that
you put in this dish
is quite subjective nuts are fried nuts
are added to it raisins are added to it
that's how a halwa or a
this is usually eaten during special
occasions but during winter
people prefer to eat it daily as a
dessert it can be even eaten with ice
cream
during summers so it is very rich in
taste
it has a good flavor of carrots and
cardamom and nut gives it a very nice
crunch
so it's a very universal dish very
appealing to the taste
and simple to eat and cook
this dessert from lebanon actually makes
my mouth water just
thinking about how good it tastes
[Music]
[Music]
like
foreign
[Music]
and finally we end with a cake that's
cooked over an open fire
and looks nothing like a cake
[Music]
[Music]
successive
foreign
i think desserts are an amazing way to
explore a country
because if you're not totally down with
trying the main parts of the cuisine
maybe you're not the most adventurous
eater
desserts are really safe place to go
plus they're usually utilizing a lot of
local ingredients and flavors
so you're still totally getting a taste
and a sense of where you are
which is great desserts look good and
they make you feel good
and they taste really good so yeah i
don't know
this has been a great week i liked it
[Music]
[Music]
because this dessert is special you
enjoy eating it with the family
[Music]
you